За 3-5 років в Україні наведуть
ідеальний порядок на дорогах,
заявив прем’єр-міністр
України Володимир Гройсман.
За його словами, вже значно
покращилась якість ремонту доріг
і українці найближчими роками
відчують зміни.
Загальна протяжність українських автошляхів
державного та місцевого значення
складає близько 170 тисяч кілометрів.
З них 95 відсотків
є зношеними
і не відповідають сучасним
вимогам.
За даними експертів,
щороку варто ремонтувати
30 тисяч кілометрів доріг. З них
половина – середній поточний ремонт
і половина – капітальний.
Але наразі Укравтодор
в середньому за рік встигає відремонтувати
менше тисячі кілометрів доріг,
як видно на цьому графіку.
А це менше 1 відсотка доріг.
Синім тут виділено
середній поточний ремонт.
Жовтим – капітальний ремонт, якого
значно менше. Причому найбільший
бум ремонту прийшовся на часи
підготовки до Євро-2012.
Цьогоріч відремонтовано сімсот кілометрів доріг.
Все зводиться до нестачі коштів, кажуть в Укравтодорі.
Середній поточний ремонт
одного кілометра дороги,
який потрібно робити кожні п’ять років,
коштує за різними даними
до десяти мільйонів гривень.
А капітальний ремонт цього ж одного кілометра,
необхідний щодесять років -
до 20-30 мільйонів гривень.
Отже, за підрахунками експертів, щоб відремонтувати ідеально
всі дороги потрібно щороку
виділяти щонайменше
100 мільярдів гривень.
І тоді, не за 3-5,
а лише за 10 років, можна буде
привести до ладу всі дороги України.
Але якщо поглянути
на сучасний рівень фінансування
ремонту доріг, то стає зрозумілим,
що і цей термін є фантастичним.
Наприклад, цьогоріч з держбюджету
Укравтодору виділили
лише 17 мільярдів гривень,
з них більше п'яти мільярдів
пішло на погашення боргів.
Тобто на ремонт доріг безпосередньо
залишилось лише 12 мільярдів.
А торік  ця сума була
на рівні 19 мільярдів гривень.
Порівнюючи цю цифру з очікуваннями експертів
щодо 100 мільярдів на рік,
стає зрозумілим, що Україна відстає
щонайменше в 5 разів.
Тобто з такими темпами
привести абсолютно всі дороги до ладу
можна буде не раніше ніж
за 50 років.
Втім в уряді сподіваються, що коштів
на ремонт стане більше, коли
з наступного року запрацює Дорожній фонд.
Він передбачає, що всі акцизні збори
та мито від нафтопродуктів,
палива та автомобілів витрачатимуть
на ремонт доріг.
Але щороку держбюджет збирає
до 35-40 мільярдів гривень
з цих зборів і мит.
Тобто навіть якщо Фонд запрацює, .
це все одно двічі менше,
ніж потрібно для швидкого приведення
до ладу доріг.
За 3-5 років зробити українські дороги
ідеальними нереально.
За тим рівнем фінансування українських доріг,
що є зараз, відремонтувати їх
буде можливо лише
за 50 років.